depuis que nicolas hulot a été accusé
d'agression et de violence sexuelle dans
l'émission envoyé spécial diffusée jeudi
soir sur france 2 il s'arrête donc après
sur un parking et la voilà et sort son
sax et langues se délier les proches de
l'ancien ministre de l'ecologie tente
tant bien que mal de se désolidariser
tes propos évidemment que je n'ai jamais
ouvert de tels agissements évidemment
que je n'ai jamais été au courant de
tels agissements le parti écologiste a
même décidé de faire le ménage en
écartant tout ce qui aurait pu être au
courant ou couvrir les agissements de
nicolas hulot pour ne pas parasiter la
campagne du candidat écologiste yannick
jadot cette affaire hulot pourrait bien
avoir des conséquences politiques
beaucoup plus large dernièrement ils ont
même demandé que certains titres
honorifiques soient ôtés à nicolas hulot
alors faut-il retirer la légion
d'honneur à nicolas hulot
alors oui gilles verdez bien sûr bien
sûr pour deux raisons d'abord une raison
morale il l'a depuis 1997 aujourd'hui à
des témoignages accablants mais comment
peut-il mérité de garder cette légion
d'honneur c'est impossible je ne préjuge
pas d'une action éventuelle en justice
mais il faut lui retirer la légion
d'honneur et dans la charte de la légion
d'honneur qui fait sens une page c'est
stipulé les actes contraires à l'honneur
sont susceptibles d'entraîner des peines
disciplinaires contraire à l'honneur on
y est donc il faut lui retirer de toute
urgence mathieu aberrant des accusations
c'est pas des condamnés sera condamné à
l'hallucinante auquel la république taux
qui défend les valeurs et dans le code
de la légion d'honneur ne s'excuserait
pas bien d'annexer l'air si
effectivement il est condamné n'a
absolument pas alors il devra
et c'est le finirai sur le code de coin
on dira le prof de la légion d'honneur
sur des témoignages la seule chose qui
comptera vraiment c'est ce qu'a
accusations pas si y'a pas accusations
eh bien il devrait garder sa médaille si
effectivement il est condamné alors il
doit rendre sa décision c'est simple
médaille qu'ils seraient entachés de
toute façon donc c'est une médaille
niang assure de coiffure je ne comprends
pas même que de lui même il se disent
pas je vais la regarder
voilà moi il devient médecin aveu de
culpabilité si le fais pour moi et vous
permet en peluche à quoi ça sert cette
légion d'honneur
non mais tu peux penser que les femmes
et je jouais pas l'image qui ont le
courage de témoigner mais qu'est ce
qu'elle sera quoi la légion d'honneur je
vous attends de la justice elle a semble
t'il parle elle a tendu le il y ait dans
lequel swype et c'est un symbole s sont
faits pour les téléspectateurs ça sert à
quoi ils ont déjà pris leurs différentes
actions si laure hestin souris que tu as
a service bah ouais
c'est la légion d'honneur et si à
personne mais vous avez là les jo
d'horreur voit
mal maintenant je n'ai aucune raison de
l'avoir a pas un mérite quelque chose
rien il émérite à l'école ni le poireau
ni les
anges et le poireau non on n'arrête pas
de répéter sur ce plateau il faut pas
condamner médiatiquement ni
professionnelle la meilleure sonorité
qui a accusé tant qu'elle n'a pas été
jugée par la
voilà donc pour moi ça n'a pas de sens
con con con qu'on condamnerait on peut
entendre ceux qui éventuellement disent
qu'il faudrait lui retirer pour la
simple et bonne raison que a priori sauf
si d'autres femmes se manifestait ya
prescription sur tous les cas cités en
l'occurrence donc il n'ira jamais en
justice donc elle sera entaché donc on
peut entendre aussi les arrivées en
justice il peut y avoir une procédure
qui est faite au sein du conseil de
l'ordre avec un avis quand on est au
président de la république même si ya
pas deux en fait c'est systématique chez
une condamnation à plus d'un an un acte
criminel mais ça ne l'est pas et il peut
y avoir une procédure
je regrette un blâme aussi récemment
mais ce que je regrette en fait c'est
que l'hypocrisie d'europe écologie les
verts il demande aujourd'hui parce qu'on
en pleine campagne électorale alors
qu'en fait ils ne se sont jamais posé la
question amuse on en vérité on se met le
droit chemin tout le monde savait alors
faut pas faire croire à quiconque
qu'europe écologie les verts qui était
totalement investie auprès de nicolas
hulot ne savais rien et aujourd'hui pour
se laver les mains ils dégagent comme
ils demandent le retrait de la légion
d'honneur dans tout le monde se fout
complètement se les est pauvre victime
elle savait même pas qu'il avait là les
fonds aideront partie reculée ya rien à
voir on la plus propre plus blanc que
blanc est là je trouve ça
y est ça m'a saoulé
franchement retirer nuit là on s'en tape
mais c'est vrai retirer une salle échoué
c'est tout allez oui la cal arrange et
puis c'est tout l'art en 70 ans des
tyrans de l'argent qui entoure son chou
est rentable et les trucs ushuaïa alors
entre foulée